construye un círculo inscrito en el
triángulo quiere decir que tenemos que
dibujar un círculo que sea tangente a
cada uno de los lados del triángulo el
que se encuentre dentro de este tengo la
forma más sencilla para hacer esto es
encontrar las líneas que dice ken o
dividan a la mitad cada uno de estos
ángulos para eso vamos a usar para eso
vamos a usar la herramienta que tenemos
aquí del compás y vamos a usar estos
círculos de manera que la punta o el
vértice del ángulo que queremos dividir
toque al círculo en un lado y voy a usar
otro círculo igual que quiero que sea
del mismo tamaño que éste éste lo voy a
ajustar a ok y lo voy a poner de este
otro lado de manera que la intersección
en ambos círculos coincida con el
vértice del ángulo que quiero cortar por
la mitad o dividir y con este punto y
este punto yo puedo tener una línea
recta que esté justo a la mitad en este
ángulo lo divide en dos utilizo regla y
este
de acá algo que coincida con este
vértice y este otro que coincida con
esta otra intersección de aquí de estos
círculos más o menos que quede lo más
preciso que se pueda aunque esta
herramienta permite cierto margen de
error tampoco hay que hacer tan tan
exactos
y para encontrar la intersección de esas
líneas que dividen los ángulos a la
mitad pues voy a tener que hacer lo
mismo en otro ángulo de este triángulo
vamos a ver este de acá a que se toque
más o menos
y ahora agarro el otro circulito lo
coloco de este lado de manera que toque
también este vértice de este ángulo que
quiero dividir a la mitad o disecar
ahora utilizo la regla y la colocó en
estas intersecciones en este punto de
acá y este de manera que coincida en
esta otra intersección de los círculos
ahí está y aquí donde se tocan estas dos
líneas va a ser el centro del círculo
inscrito en el triángulo o adentro del
triángulo y voy a hacer un lado uno de
estos círculos que ya no me interesan y
voy a tomar este otro colocó el centro
aquí en esa intersección y lo que me
queda es ajustar el tamaño del círculo
para que toque más o menos los lados del
triángulo más o menos así vamos a ver
comprobar nuestra respuesta muy bien